songwriting is about your experiences
and it expands your vocabulary in terms
of the way you see the world music is
something that people can connect with
and
feel an emotion
there was a few really cool underground
spots where i would go and listen to
jazz in dubai and i'd see all these
musicians and i'd be like yeah that's
where i want to be at
i'm moana davis i'm daniel
together we are architects and
photographers our approach is to play
with perspectives and geometry within an
urban landscape
and as architects we travel the world
exploring unseen aspects of buildings so
we can tell stories to the image
we are on a journey to meet with other
like-minded and inspiring creatives in
dubai
[Music]
here we meet with leila karen a bold new
performer who is breaking perceptions of
what it means to be a female singer in
the middle east we first meet leila in
devised all neighborhoods of al-fahedi
i think both of you being architects you
can appreciate that it's such a
completely different architecture to
what you typically see in dubai yeah not
many skyscrapers
we were living in australia and my
father was really excited about the
great opportunity in dubai so he moved
us here it was such a different world to
what i'd seen you know growing up in
sydney but it became you know a home for
us i have really beautiful memories as a
child growing up in in dubai and got to
learn a lot about the culture
you really feel the history and the
heritage of the people when you come to
the creek really interesting alleyways
in these bazaars where you'll see spice
markets fabric merchants cellars of
antique jewelry and all of that is a
feast for the eyes
i like to reference traditional middle
eastern instruments just because i love
the sounds of them but in in a subtle
way i like the wood more as a drum beat
and warp it and distort it but it's
still there
it's a very clever way to make a very
historical instrument not to lost in the
history and use it in a more
contemporary way i think it's
fascinating actually
[Music]
even though you feel you're in such a
modern city
you know you're in dubai you're not in
in america or in europe because
they always have this traditional touch
in everything they do
at night the whole city comes alive and
we begin to understand how dubai's music
scene has become a crucial part of the
night life here
in the last three years there's live
music all over town before we would go
to this one spot to watch jazz music and
now you can in one night i can name like
seven or eight or even more places
[Music]
wanting to share more intimate side to
the music scene
layla invites us to nafta party where we
meet the community of musicians that she
collaborates with guys this is a
complete jam so we don't even know what
we're doing sorry
and that's another thing i love about
dubai is that i've got an incredible
band of musicians from all over the
world
wherever you go in the world it's
important to
see the culture and the music
i think it's the first thing that
teaches us tolerance is when you
understand a little bit about a person's
culture and where they're from music is
a very beautiful way to share a message
this time with leila has given us the
opportunity to see dubai's strong
artistic circle allowing inspiration and
vision among musicians to be shared
through collaboration
an experience we won't forget and a
music scene we were unaware of before
coming
yes sir
[Music]